as that's
damn it's got an old Snoop Dogg on me
low back
right welcome to the next level kitchen
where we're taking your skills to the
next level with some amazing tips and
fantastic delicious recipes and Gordon
today we're taking two slices of bread
and turning it into something amazing I
promise you it is not an idiot sandwich
so it is a delicious Next Level steak
sandwich that everyone in your household
will be a huge fan after you produce
this amazing steak sandwich let me tell
you
um so I'm gonna use a strip loin a
beautiful strip line which I'm gonna use
that fat to help render the onions and
slice it at the very last minute we're
using man I love fat fattest flavor but
I'm gonna use the leanest piece I'm
gonna use a filet mignon and I'm gonna
make a homemade aioli with it wow okay
great now first things first take this
steak house okay a Next Level tip is to
make sure it comes out of the fridge get
up to room temperature and give it a
really good season okay now when you
look at this New York strip you think
God it's too big for a sandwich but
here's how you get the yield okay I
lightly
smear it with a little touch
of oil okay take my rolling pin and just
roll that steak
just till it gets nice and flat what
happens here is I mop up all that
seasoning and by Rolling the steak it
actually forces the seasoning inside the
steak it's a great tip get this done
literally 20 minutes before you go to
cook it and inside is permeated with
that amazing seasoning I love it I love
it yeah over here we're gonna do like a
barbecue spice blend I have some of my
favorite flavors we have cumin we have
garlic we have onion we have paprika and
we have a little bit of brown sugar
which I love with red meat and real
simple we're just going to season our
filet mignon again it's really really uh
lean so we want all we want to crusted
in these flavors and use whatever
flavors you want here so I got my dusted
fillet it smells amazing already and of
course I'm gonna get start cooking that
my Pan's getting hot hot pan a little
bit of oil I love cooking in cast iron
with red meat because you get that nice
sear on it and look at this it is it's
blazing in here Gordon it is blazing now
I'm using a sourdough bread okay and
I'll come back to the minute but get the
crust on that amazing steak and the
garnish I'm going to keep this really
simple I'm gonna fry some onions which
are delicious with the steak but more
importantly look I'm gonna flip that
steak use some of that fat to start
cooking these onions now I'm using a
white onion because it's a lot more
robust than the Red Onion so it's going
to go really nice and caramelize now
first of all turn that steak over
okay take out some of the fat into that
pan there
and this is a great tip by the way then
start frying your onions in that pan
now come on the steak the onions I've
got the fat from that New York strip
already in those onions and now we start
going up a level I've got some
salt
and I've got a little bit of brown sugar
here I just watched what happens those
onions they start to caramelize so quick
it gets rid of that raw sort of white
onion flavor and it bodes well with that
beautiful red meat
rich I love that okay so I don't have
fat because I got filet mignon so I need
some fat so I'm gonna make a homemade
aioli or a garlic mayonnaise tip when
you're making mayonnaise get a wet rag
put it on your board so that the bowl
doesn't swirl around and then it's just
two egg yolks some garlic a little bit
of mustard the mustard is going to help
with the emulsification uh and then I'm
just gonna start whisking whisking like
a madman to make a homemade mayonnaise
you don't have to buy it you just have a
little bit of patience and again because
the steak is so lean this is gonna add
some fat and some flavor to it this is
gonna be my sauce okay Gordon what do
you got so onions the camera lies down
beautifully you can see where that brown
sugar is doing I've got the fat from the
New York strip in there I'm gonna go
back in with some excess fat again so
the flavor is connected and I promise
you it really is an amazing Next Level
tip now this is where the onions go up a
level I've got some age vastly vinegar
and what I'm gonna do now is easily
reduce
that vinegar over the onion so think
about it I've got the caramel with the
sugar I've got the useful flavor from
that New York strip and now those onions
just become almost like a beautiful
sweet sour
with that steak I love that I love that
sweet potatoes where it's at all right
so now I'm going to baste this I got the
filet I threw some garlic in there and
some thyme uh and now what I'm going to
do is real simple I'm just going to sort
of baste this fillet or you can also get
it in the oven if you want right now
here's the thing about filet this looks
really dark but remember it's got all
these dark spices on it this is still
rare pop it in the oven or listen filet
is one of the few meats that you can eat
rare it's gonna still be super super
delicious so what I'm gonna do is
actually let this rest and keep it nice
and rare uh in mid-rare here love that
okay so now you can see by Rolling that
steak nice and flat I've got that crust
so when we come to slice this thing I've
got texture and I want it mid-rare okay
so I leave it
to rest I take it out of my pan okay I
cover will that be used for resting
juices over there and just let it sit
there for a couple of minutes now check
out the onions
you can do these onions up for sort of
three four days in advance and it
becomes like this onion jam and the
flavor is incredible great with chicken
sandwiches as well as a New York strip
okay I've got my sourdough bread
but how do I Elevate that I got some
beautiful swiss cheese let's go into my
pan
and I'm just going to get that melting
now I love this trick trust me a touch
of salt a touch of pepper and watch what
happens to that cheese again Richard
what is the cheese the cheese tip is
like I am here for you I'm totally
taking that you're gonna see it in all
of my restaurants
as that starts to caramelize got this
beautiful flavor this amazing swiss
cheese that is just caramelizing in your
pan
no no butter no mayonnaise just get your
bread and mop up
that beautiful flavor
and just roll it around and look again
Rich what are you doing with your
breasts I love it I'm just throwing mine
on the grill look at that I don't know
what I'm showing you I'm just just happy
with it love that good job so I love
that you had a little bit of the Char
you don't have to toast in a pan or in a
toaster just throw your bread on a grill
and I'm gonna do an Open Face Sandwich
so I have my steak that's resting I have
my bread now here's where uh we're gonna
get we're gonna get blazed in here
Gordon I love that time to get blazed we
have some tomatoes on the vine a little
salt pepper olive oil and then listen
it's time for the torch it's time for
the torch you're torching the sandwich
I'm torching the tomatoes and just
blistering these tomatoes to be a
garnish for the sandwich with olive oil
salt pepper and I will have the acidity
and the sweetness from these Tomatoes I
don't know if it's gonna match those
onions but they look delicious over
there smell incredible that's a great
way of sort of caramelizing those
tomatoes so a quick little blowtorch
and again if you don't have a blowtorch
throw them in the pan throw them on the
grill throw them in the broiler but
there we go some charred Tomatoes I'm
almost ready to build my sandwich you go
no good over there I am absolutely good
now toast is out okay
this
is where you start to take your steak
sandwich up to another level I've got my
base I've got my top okay first off
I've got a little bit of horseradish
cream okay one beautiful layer on that
caramelized swiss cheese horseradish
delicious now the top half I've got some
beautiful mustard once you've got that
mustard mixed into that cheese it's on a
different level how do I bring that heat
down
what's peppery and delicious and goes
well with an amazing steak sandwich
beautiful Watercress that's going to sit
on the top now
from there
my onions the smell of these onions
honestly it's just
so good just look the steak's not even
on there yet and it looks so good
I'm gonna slice my steak until you say
we can go Richard let's go let's go
slice my steak Pro tip over here after
the meat is sliced a little bit more
seasoning on the pieces that were not uh
seasoned already and now I have my
grilled bread I'm gonna put my Oli right
down on the bread again I like a lot of
this right you have all this crunchy
texture from the baguette you have a
nice smear uh of our steak you know what
I think I have some of this this rocket
we'll throw down some of this arugula or
rocket right on the bottom of the
sandwich right here and here's the tip
yeah you saw me flattening that steak
out earlier yeah yeah the yield is for
two I've only used half the steak and
look at that on there and honestly just
give that a little season every time we
expose protein and you slice it give it
a little season and then look just a
touch of the reduction from my onion so
I'm going to pour over the steak
and now we go up a level take my
beautiful lid and then we're just going
to close that over in fact
dear God may this be the most delicious
steak sandwich I've ever made here we go
and then boom finally
a little press down
on a slice it and a half
beautifully I'm gonna open it up
and that
is fit
for a king
and then finally I got a little touch of
watercress that's going to sit there
on the sides something green and mean
Richard there we go I'm going to serve
my open face I'm I'm watching my carbs
I'm gonna put it right over here right
on the plate we have an open faced
filet sandwich with these charred
Tomatoes a little bit of arugula salad
I don't know I think they're both
looking pretty pretty delicious
[Music]
two amazing sandwiches and I promise you
that's how you take your sandwich to the
next level now to get the ingredients
and more details on the fabulous recipes
from tonight's cook-off please check the
description below and be sure to
subscribe for more episodes of Next
Level kitchen with this genius great job
[Music]